c'était le premier procès dans cette
affaire qui dure depuis dix ans à
l'annoncé du jugement au tribunal de
dijon
les proches de la victime ne cachent pas
leur douleur je suis effondré par cette
décision qui a été rendue
cette peine est dérisoire face leur
implication de responsabilité au décès
de mon petit les deux jeunes gens tu été
reconnu coupable par la justice de ne
pas avoir porté secours à jonathan
vantillard battu à mort la nuit du 13
avril 2007
en plus des peines d'emprisonnement avec
sursis ils sont condamnés à verser plus
de 40000 euros de dédommagement à la
partie civile
le seul apaisement possible et encore
parce que lorsqu'on perd un enfant je
crois qu'il ya pas d'apaisement possible
mais au moins une possibilité de faire
le deuil c'est de pouvoir interpeller
enfin les auteurs de ce crime odieux et
à défaut d'interpeller ces personnes et
bien encore une fois on tape lourdement
très lourdement sur deux personnes qui
je crois à l'époque avait 20 ans et que
personne n'aurait imaginé encore une
fois le drame qui est en train de se
jouer dans cette cour les deux prévenus
étaient absents lors de l'annoncé de ce
jugement en délibéré
leurs avocats envisagent de faire appel
dans cette affaire ce procès n'aura en
tout cas pas permis d'en savoir plus sur
ce qui est vraiment arrivé à jonathan
vantillard